Hey, I've got a voicemail today at two one
nine two David p, which is a voicemail tattling
to me about something crazy that Sam Cedar
said.
Take a listen to this.
Hey David, this is Michael from Boston.
Wanted to speak with you about same cedars
comments the other day about being in favor
of the straight pride parade.
Oh yeah.
I'm wanting to see if you were also in favor
of the straight pride parade.
I feel pretty.
Give me a call back.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
I'm so shocked.
How could Sam seed or do this?
How could Sam Cedar abandon everything that
is good and wholesome and say he supports
a straight pride parade?
I can't believe Sam would do that and I am
going to really have to give them a piece
of my mind about this because he is dividing
the progressive movement by support.
Give me a break.
Okay.
We've got a great bonus show today.
I hope that you will subscribe@wwwdotjoinpacman.com
and get the bonus show.
Get a 40% discount with the coupon code.
This is 2020 why not the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.